[Musique]
7h45 elizabeth martichoux sauver ce
matin françois bayrou bonjour françois
bon jour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
vous sauriez ministre de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui vous condamnerez les
manifestations policiers non autorisées
je les condamne aurait sans doute
verbalement mais je vais comprendrait
il ya aujourd'hui
sentiment de d'une absence de
reconnaissance de la difficulté du
travail et aussi probablement de
mauvaise organisation du travail et
c'est vrai pour les forces de l'ordre
mais c'est vrai aussi dans un climat
général dans la société française pour
qui la fonction publique est regardé
comme
peut estimer
taillables et corvéables à merci vous
avez entendu ce que un certain nombre de
personnalités 10d des enseignants des
professeurs
le accusé de ne pas travailler
de au fond d'être planqué mais oui mais
nicolas sarkozy mais aussi alain juppé
puisse copains et d'enseignants et aussi
bruno le maire estime aujourd'hui c'est
dans leurs programmes que les
enseignants en viendra aux policiers
après devrait passer plus d'heures que
sein de l'école et que j'ai entendu hier
j'ai entendu hier
nicolas sarkozy puisque vous le citez
dire l'épreuve travail six mois par an
c'est une déclarations insultantes et
comment dirais-je même pas arithmétique
pas ce que je vais vous dire une bribe
est arrivé je veux pire que ça il est
arrivé à six mois par an parce que les
profs sont censés travailler 181 jours
et si en effet vous divisez 180 jours
par ci par trente jours vous arrivez à
six mois mais que je sache il ya vingt
jours de travail par mois c'est donc
neuf mois et tout ce travail là il est
doublé par les préparations par les
conseils de classe par les entretiens
avec des parents pas
les bulletins de classe qu'il faut
remplir ses qui vient là quelque chose
c'est une simplification qui vous choque
au nom des enseignants ce n'est pas
seulement que ça me choque je trouve ça
insupportable c'est le métier le plus
difficile et c'est un métier parmi les
plus difficiles parce que policier c'est
extrêmement difficile aussi je je veux
dire simplement que pas un de ceux qui
profèrent ces propos ne tiendrait trois
heures devant une classe qu'il vous vous
dites à nicolas sarkozy
monsieur l'ancien président allait tenir
une classe je ne le nie mme barrette
forme parce que je suis trop choqués
pour cela ça prouverait quelque chose
qui serait de l'ordre du sourire jeudi
que ceux qui s'expriment de cette
manière là n'ont aucune idée de la
difficulté de ce métier et parler
uniquement des heures de présence devant
la classe c'est comme si on disait que
vous journalistes vous n'êtes au micro
que une heure par jour et que donc de ce
point de vue là vous êtes des
paresseux eux je trouve que c'est un
climat de soupçon à l'égard de
l'ensemble de la fonction publique dans
le pays qui est pour moi irrecevable en
corner de fracturer le pays voilà vous
dites que nicolas sarkozy entretient
finalement ce soupçon est ce qu on fait
un lien avec les manifestations de
policiers qui défient l'autorité
publique est ce qu'il ya une forme
d'affaiblissement de l'automobile de
l'autorité publique quand on voit des
policiers qui vont défier ainsi leur
ministre il ya une société qui se fera
la figure 1 dans les fissures de cette
société là qu'on a laissé faire depuis
15 ans dans les fissures de plus que ça
a sans doute dans les fissures de cette
société là il y à des comportements qui
sont purement et simplement inacceptable
ecône a favorisé je vais vous dire par
exemple par une décision extrêmement
graves le jour on a supprimé la police
de proximité
la police de proximité ça s'arrange pas
si vous perdez l'expression vaut votre
jugement est votre relation avec nicolas
sarkozy
j'ai dit et passez moi l'expression mais
c'est ce qu'on ressent quand on vous en
vous et moi on est un micro d'une radio
sérieuses devant une situation sérieuse
et de ce point de vue là on a le droit
de critiquer des décisions sans être
taxé d'obsession je ne suis pas obsédé
je vois un pays en train de se défaire
dans lequel se sont créés des
comportements qui sont des comportements
qui rendent impossible la vie en société
les forces de sécurité en souffrent les
enseignants en souffre et au lieu de
supporter ou deux au lieu de soutenir
ceux qui sont dans cette difficulté on
les critique et on les accuse eh bien le
rôle d'un responsable de l'état doit
être de rassurer ce qui représente
l'état de les défendre et de les
soutenir et en même temps de penser à la
manière dont on reconstruit une société
alors c'est un anti portrait d'alain
juppé peut-être que vous faites là et
vous êtes
vous êtes satisfait que les centristes
de l'udf soutiennent votre candidat j'ai
dit depuis longtemps que tous ceux qui
se réclament du centre se retrouveraient
autour de la candidature la plus proche
je dis pas la même mais la plus
compatible alain juppé il offre
aujourd'hui à la france une main une
chance que probablement elle n'a pas eu
depuis longtemps qui est une chance de
construction d'une vie politique
nouvelle dans laquelle nous avons nous
aurons
là la chance de sortir du sectarisme
dans lequel on vit depuis des années et
son choix à lui qui est d'élargir sa
base pour associer le plus de force au
pouvoir et d'équilibré au pouvoir est un
choix juste et prometteur ce qui peut
étonner quand même c'est que l'argent
christophe lagarde a tout de suite été
associés à la campagne d'alain juppé
vous non je prends un exemple alain
juppé vient à bayonne à
saint-jean-de-luz à biarritz samedi et
dans un journal d'opinion je lis ce
matin que vous qui n'ira pas paume c'est
pas très loin j'ai regardé une centaine
de kilomètres mais quoi il craint de
s'afficher avec vous parce qu'elle
savait faire fuir les électeurs de
chapleau bas il se trouve que samedi où
alain juppé vient dans les plaines
atlantiques je ne suis pas à pau
parce que nous avons un conseil national
du mouvement démocrate atteint et que
j'inaugure l'après-midi une place
jacques duhamel sa famille me demande et
olivier duhamel demandé de le faire et
c'est pour moi très précieux et je
comprends ça tout à fait mais au fond
des s'il vous plaît à la question vous
ne faites pas la campagne physiquement
d'alain juppé vous n'êtes pas avec lui
vous n'êtes pas au meeting à moi que
vous nous annonciez que vous serez par
exemple au zénith le 14 novembre avec
lui sur la scène bon ma place ou mon
rôle dans cette campagne n'est pas de
participer de cette manière là au
meeting aux réunions pour la raison que
il ya une partie de l'électorat qui sans
doute a été en désaccord avec moi dans
les années précédentes et ajuster 4 vous
êtes un peu vous pourriez être un
problème juste je ne suis pas un
problème pour alain juppé ceux qui me
soutiennent sont une chance pour lui
vous avez vu depuis le début si vous
regardez les enquêtes d'opinion je ne
doute pas que vous le fassiez que 95 %
de l'électorat du centre en france est
prêt à voter alain juppé
permettez moi de dire que je suis sans
doute pour quelque chose alors vous
attendez quoi de lui il a dit qu'il
prendrait plutôt une femme peut-être
comme premier ministre donc ce serait
pas vous je prends si c'est le cas il
vous a promis quoi un groupe au
parlement eh bien il se trouve que je ne
je n'ai pas de relation avec lui sur le
mode du marchandage peut-être ça vous
étonne mais je crois moi que
alain juppé qui a choisi de proposer une
solution politique nouvelle pour le pays
il reconnaît la force ou la présence ou
l'impact de chacun de ceux qui le
soutiennent et naturellement chacun de
ceux qui le soutiennent trouvera sa
place dans le futur dispositif est ce
que livre de confidences de françois
hollande est un suicide politique
alors je les lui honnêtement c'est
d'abord j'ai du mérite parce qu'il est
long
je comprends pas très bien ce que
françois hollande a fait recevant
pendant des heures et des dizaines
d'heures et des centaines d'heures
dégoût des groupes de journalistes
pour ce faire lui-même l'historiographe
j'imagine des cinq années qu'il a
passées à l'elysée je comprends pas très
bien ça et je ne comprends pas très bien
qu'il n'ait pas exigé de relire
les la soirée et on lui a dit non il
n'est pas allé au delà parmi les jeux
nous donne pas d'interview sans relire
oui parmi les innombrables révélations
françois bayrou le président confie
avoir décidé au moins quatre assassinats
ciblés pendant son mandat sans doute des
djihadistes mais d'autres présidents
fait davantage dit-il comme pour se
justifier ce qui a valu cette réplique
de jean marc ayrault un président ne
devrais pas dire ça c'est un bon titre
c'est un désaveu du président par son
ancien premier ministre et actuel
titulaire du quai d'orsay quelles
conséquences ça peut voir et ces trois
là est ce qu elle vous paraît très grave
brossant finances c'est une phrase qui
ne devrait pas trouver sa place dans un
livre de confidences c c'est une manière
de
d'exploser sur la place publique ce
qu'il y a de plus lourd dans la fonction
présidentielle
et ça ne peut se faire qu'en conscience
profonde et sûrement pas être étalés
devant les médias c'est pas la hauteur
ce n'est pas adapté merci beaucoup
françois bayrou d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin sur rtl commentaire de françois
bayrou sur les difficultés nos policiers
sentiment d'une absence de
reconnaissance est sans doute une
mauvaise organisation nous a dit le
président du modem sur nos profs je
trouve insupportable les propos de
nicolas sarkozy sur le travail des
professeurs et enfin sur alain juppé je
ne suis pas un problème pour lui mais
une chance et je n'ai pas de relation
avec lui sur le mode du marchandage
l'entretien est à retrouver sur le site
rtl.fr merci à tous les deux